[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and ron darling a baseball analyst for
tbs he'll be joining brian anderson for
the call tonight's win or go home
nationally divisional series between the
giants and the dodgers that starts at
nine eastern on tbs ron good to talk to
you this morning
introduce us to the giants
oh boy um what a team you know just a
magical kind of year for them whether
it's
their older players that have
performed above what you thought they
could do whether the players that
they've acquired that you didn't think
would be great to have been and then
their stuff off the bench uh best pin
shading team uh just to really honestly
every time they needed something to
happen it happened for them and uh that
that boat seems to bode well for game
five but you also and i don't know if
you believe in this when you have that
lineup that doesn't have the true star
it feels like they probably think hey
one of us has to step up tonight not
just rely on hey mookie betts has to
stay you know stand up there that it
almost feels like it's more dangerous
with that lineup that feels like one of
us has to take ownership tonight
you know dan that's a really good point
i think that they have spent the entire
year
uh with people saying that at some point
they will decline they will not play
well they'll be out of it the dodgers
will overtake them and each and every
time they they have stepped up and i
think they've done that
probably better than any team as far as
mass
maximizing their you know 30 or 40 man
roster everyone that came up when you
think about their closure right now as a
kid that was up and down four times that
didn't perform well until september and
now he might be the difference maker
if they move ahead
explain these two pictures because i
looked and i don't think they've lost in
it's been a long time but you know
between these two like 39 starts does
that sound uh accurate for these two
going into this game
it does it does in fact if you if you
look at webb he hasn't lost since may
5th
if you look at urias uh he has on his
last 23 starts with the
dodgers they're 19 and three
so um they just when they take the mound
uh the home team wins so um it's gonna
be interesting to watch you know the one
uh i guess advantage maybe is that urias
has been there so many times at 25 years
old he's got seven
post season wins which is remarkable um
but this slogan webb kid has
just had
like the dodge i like the giants an
amazing magical year everything has gone
his way so you know we're
us skeptics are always
wondering when it's going to end um but
those people that are think of great
magical endings are thinking that's
always going to go on so who knows do
the giants have a lineup though that you
would think it was not built for that
ballpark um
but but they are they're home run
hitters everybody in the lineup can hit
home runs
uh are we getting to the point where it
doesn't matter what ballpark teams are
playing in
that's the better point dan um it
doesn't matter where you play now if
you've got guys who have power um
defenses really are irrelevant although
in san francisco they've moved defenses
in 10 feet or less
and three or four different areas in
that ballpark and in center field it's
391 feet and i remember when i was a kid
playing in the cape cod league uh dennis
yarmouth center field was like 385 we
thought that was the most ridiculous
center field of all time so think about
these big leaguers with the big muscles
trying to hit the ball uh 391 that
really is a difference maker but i go
back to i think cleveland had a center
field of 454 if yeah
like many many many years ago like
that's crazy to have a center field that
deep and uh you know fenway's not deep
that's not even 400.
yeah cleveland uh a remember forbes
field in pittsburgh they used to they
used to use the batting cage with the
guys hit on before the game they used to
just park it in center field because
they figured that no one could hit the
ball out of the ballpark there so you
know there was some uh yankee stadium of
course uh uh you know all of the
monuments were in play uh at some point
so certainly the game uh and the
ballparks have changed circle two guys
tonight one for each team where you say
you know this this is the guy that's the
key for the giants this is the guy the
key for the dodgers
uh okay for for the giants i'm not going
to say a guy but i do think because of
their pinch hitting numbers they're they
have 18 home runs from pin [ __ ]
they've had some magical times a late
night lamont way junior you you get that
nickname because you're you're great
late in the game i think he might do
something for the giants and i think uh
when i look at the dodger team with all
their stars the guy that has been the
best from the 17th seventh inning on and
later to include the postseason who has
eight home runs to tie the game or put
them ahead as their catcher will smith
those are the two guys i would look at
tonight
we talk about the playoff format
sometimes we look at the end results and
then we're like oh you got to reseed you
know everybody's angry now the one game
playoff it's the you know that should
the dodgers be in a one game plan my
thought is how about we say this before
we start this season not when because if
you had some teams that weren't
nationally known nobody would be
screaming about this but you put the
dodgers or yankees in a situation like
this then we want change could you see
baseball reseeding
or could you see it more than a one-game
playoff again
yeah i i think
i can't see them
well i think the reseeding thing makes
more sense in this in this way i would
see
someday that baseball will have no
divisions that will be the national
league and the american league and in
this this scenario you'd have the
dodgers and the giants who have the best
record you'll probably maybe include six
teams instead of uh
instead of the uh five teams we have now
so six teams in each league
two series of three games between uh
three and four and
uh so three and four and five and six
and then the teams that had the best
records in the game would play those
teams after that so uh they are assured
at least of getting into the division
series
john smold said how about if you have
that
one game playoff that the team that has
the you know fewer wins has to beat that
team twice while the team that has the
more wins they only have to win one game
i i like that too i mean john thinks
about these things all the time and he
has some really great ideas the only
problem you have is that if you beat a
team twice you have to be the team twice
it puts you into a pitching situation
where you might not be competitive the
rest of the the next division series so
i wouldn't want to put a team in a place
where they use their number one they use
their number two they have to fight to
use the entire bullpen and get to the
first game and they have to do a bullpen
game or you have someone from uh
shortstop pitching so i would never want
to see i see that
do you still hold a grudge with anybody
you played against
do i ever halt grudge against anyone i
played against um
no i i think the longer you live on this
planet after your professional athlete
the only grudge you hold is against
yourself
when you think about i think i was at
dodgers stadium two days ago and they
were celebrating the 1988 team
and uh
and as i was talking to jaime harin
their
radio
announcer for the last 63 years he said
you know ron it's the it's the uh
it's the anniversary of the 1988 dodgers
i said jaime i only lasted an inning in
the seventh game so it's not a
celebration for me so i kind of hold the
grudge against myself you know
so it was pretty funny i couldn't help
but watch the documentary on you know
your mets back in the uh the mid 80s
what'd you think well i i loved it but
but i was there uh around that i worked
at cnn in new york so i i was around you
guys you goofballs um
but i but i started to wonder we've had
these one-and-done teams that were so
good
but they only won once
if you were going to put your finger on
why that match team only won once
what would it be
well i i think uh that's a great point i
think that uh maybe
maturity uh might be one of them but
honestly uh that team felt like a you
know like a open aids team it felt like
a uh
it felt like a cincinnati reds team
but we're destined to always live with
uh not a team of destiny but a team that
had an amazing year
but but i think that we could have been
a little more mature
uh with
how we approached uh the longevity of
what we were trying to do how about that
finish this sentence if dwight goodman
had stayed clean
i would have been able to go
to cooperstown and listen to him give a
great speech yeah
you know ronnie i went i paid to go see
a game and i think it was like may it
was in may um and it was
dennis martinez and the expos at shea
against doc and i i paid for seats
behind home plate because i wanted to
watch
i wanted to this is 84 maybe i wanted to
watch i wanted to hear that fastball i
wanted to watch that curveball
yeah like i was that fascinated and i
could have gotten probably you know
press credentials i wanted to sit behind
home plate and uh
i oh my god el presidente was awesome i
mean i loved
dennis martinez but doc gooden was just
that was different that was that was
that was different
you know uh
el presidente once i got traded to the
expos i was only there for about a week
or so before i moved on to the a's he
took a perfect game in los angeles while
i was there so i got to see in the
uniform the perfect game and boy what a
pitcher uh with capital p-i-t-c-h-e-r
he was but as far as doc was concerned
you know i lived in the city for my
entire career with the mets and he was
the only athlete
that i had ever played with heard about
went to see
that the whole city would be buzzing if
he pitched on a friday night i mean the
entire city you would go to lunch people
will ask you about them you would walk
down the street tell doc hello
it was that kind of phenomenon and i
think we have i don't know like as a
society we love when teenagers can beat
old men it's one of the coolest things i
think and that's what doc had working
but did you think if you were banking on
hall of fame you saw strawberry and you
saw goodin
who would you have bet on if they were
if they were stocks which one would you
bought
i i would have bought both because i i
thought if you asked me that i would
have said it
i wouldn't have said it then but i say
it now
um they were
bons and clemens
and
that's the kind of career arc they were
on and ironically bonds and clements
aren't in the whole team either so but
that's the that's the kind of career
that those two
were supposed to have you know 600 home
runs
300 wins
[Music]
4 000 strikeouts
uh 2000 rbis that that's where they were
going and uh
you know
it's it's a it's a shame but also um i
love those two guys so um i'm happy that
they're in a good place right now
i'm happy they're still alive ron
yeah i mean that's really what it comes
down to
you know there are a lot doc's alive i
mean that
doc doc's alive daryl is thriving um you
know as uh as a preacher and and and
trying to talk to people about some of
the mistakes he's made you know they're
they're trying really hard to do great
with their lives uh what what better uh
thing than that you know
great to talk to you have fun tonight
and uh thanks for joining us as always
ron
oh thank you dan appreciate it bye
that's ronnie darling